chers amis bonjour à tous
vous pouvez pas savoir le plaisir que ça
me fait d'être ici aujourd'hui
aussi est il de votre parti j'avoue que
moi j'ai pas le droit de dire de parler
de politique nationale mais france à
françois sait très bien que je me sens
je me sens vraiment chez moi ici
alors quand françois m'a proposé de
venir mais dit tu peux faire une vidéo
[Musique]
je dis non non je viens je veux être
parmi vous même si ses parts par les
moyens que nous devons tous respecter
je tenais vraiment à être là cet après
midi d'abord pour partager avec vous ma
première année de commissaire européen
vous avez un commissaire européen bien
sûr qu'ils partagent évidemment vos
valeurs donc je vais vous faire un peu
ce petit bilan dire aussi que c'est pour
moi l'occasion évidemment nous retrouver
de retrouver françois que j'ai jamais
quitté s'affairant compter tout à
l'heure ça va faire bientôt 40 ans qu'on
se connaît avec françois et qu'on sait
et qu'on sait pas qui tu es donc donc la
fidélité c'est aussi une des valeurs de
valeurs cardinales que vous partagez que
nous partageons tout ce qui va aussi
avant de commencer évidemment pour celui
qui nous a quittés qui a été évidemment
un très grand président un grand
réformateur
on n'oublie pas évidemment le rôle qu'il
a joué pour notre pays qu'il a joué
aussi pour pour l'udf en faire le party
de partis pas dont nous sommes issus
dont je suis issue c'est à travers lui
des affairés à travers monory rené
monory que que je que je vous ai rejoint
évidemment je suis aussi de penser pour
rené monory aujourd'hui puisque c'est le
moment des dépenses et voilà alors on va
faire un petit bilan
si vous le voulez bien de cette première
année parce qu'il se trouve que c'est
aussi le premier anniversaire quasiment
jour pour jour où dans les circonstances
que vous connaissez
j'ai été j'ai été coopté et puis et puis
le parlement européen a soutenu ma
candidature en tant que commissaire
européen alors au marché intérieur en
fait il ya un tout petit peu plus parce
que vous savez que le président de la
république avait souhaité avoir pour le
commissaire français où la commissaire
français à portefeuille assez large je
reconnais qu'il est assez large marché
intérieur évidemment l'industrie le
numérique la défense l'espace le
tourisme les médias c'est un
portefeuille large et c'est n'importe
quoi je crois à la dimension des enjeux
qui nous attendions à venir je vais
revenir dans un petit instant si vous le
voulez bien évidemment si on veut faire
ce bilan puisque crois que c'est
important pour nous projeter sur les
années qui vont venir et notamment les
années électorales
moi je tire d'abord évidemment le regard
comme nous tous de l'impact de la crise
rien la crise elle est encore là on a
maintenant suffisamment de recul pour
tirer un certain nombre de conclusions
on peut dire déjà de cette première
vague
comment elle a vécu à bruxelles
évidemment bien on l'a vécue et je l' ai
vécu moi en tant que commissaire au
marché intérieur de plein fouet
je ne vous cache pas que dès les
premières l'apparition de cette crise
totalement inédite et soudaine l'europe
a donné un visage qui n'est pas le
visage que l'on veut pour l'europe
l'europe s'est refermée sur elle-même
pendant quelques jours c'est évidemment
la sidération c'était la crainte de ne
pas avoir suffisamment de médicaments de
ne pas avoir suffisamment de matériel de
protection pour les personnels de santé
et à parent c'était ma responsabilité je
suis chargé de faire fonctionner le
marché intérieur
j'ai appelé l'ensemble des ministres de
la santé l'industrie puis en quelques
jours
les frontières se sont ouvertes en
quelques jours nous avons re compris
qu'il était absolument essentiel de
partager en quelques jours nous avons
vraiment vu que ce qui était nécessaire
pour une crise de cette nature c'était
évidemment que l'on puisse la traiter au
niveau d'un continent au niveau de notre
continent
vous savez c'est assez c'est très très
fort pour moi ce moment parce que j'ai
dit à mes collaborateurs au fond
le mot qui va ressortir de cette crise
ça va être la solidarité c'était avant
le plan de relance c'était avant tout ce
qu'on a fait sur les vaccins et j'ai
senti très vite que c'était ce mot qui
allait faire la différence qu'ils
allaient nous faire vraiment prendre
compte alors nous on sait on est des
européens convaincus mais même pour ceux
qui le sont moins que nous qu'il fallait
aller faire vraiment prendre conscience
que finalement c'est à travers ce mot
que l'europe existe et et puis on a eu
on a commencé à mettre en commun nos
ressources nos forces
l'europe comme tous les autres
continents du monde et tous les autres
pays d'une façon générale on va préparer
je me souviens avoir parenthèse que
c'est moi qui conseillait regard de la
vente dans la vienne au moins janvier
d'envoyer des masques de protection aux
chinois qui le demandaient pas ce qui
n'était pas préparé eux-mêmes dans le
cadre de nos accords de coopération
donc personne n'était préparé en
l'espace de trois quatre mois des
industriels européens se sont mobilisés
on a été auto suffisant et puis et puis
il ya eu ce plan évidemment de relance
ce plan de relance qui a ancrée au plus
profond désormais je pense notre adn
la solidarité le principe de solidarité
le fait que dans cette crise tous les
pays les 27 états membres devaient être
égaux devant cette nécessité
cette nécessité de s'endetter parce que
évidemment pas un seul des états du
monde n'avait le premier euro vaillant
le premier de dollars pour pouvoir faire
face à cette crise touche ont dû
procéder l'endettement un petit point là
dessus françois connaît mon aversion à
la dette
quoique nous la partageons mon cher
pense qu'en tout cas on sait que c'est
un sujet absolument essentiel mais enfin
pour cette crise là on a oublié
évidemment ce qu'est ce que l'on se
disait françois et on s'est dit et toi
et moi que c'était absolument essentiel
de donner à l'ensemble des pays
européens
une capacité identique à procès a
procédé à l'endettement puisque
l'allemagne a dû s'endetter
les pays bas ont dû s'endetter la france
devait s'endetter l'espagne l'italie la
grèce le portugal tous les pays
européens ont dû s'endetter
fallait-il encore qu'ils puissent le
faire dans des conditions identiques ça
a été ce fameux plan de relance
évidemment qui a ancré
la solidarité pour lequel on l'a bien vu
c'est une réalité
je crois qu'on peut dire historique le
président de la république emmanuel
macron et la chancelière merkel ont
vraiment pesé de tout leur poids
c'était bien préparé par la commission
je veux le dire mais politiquement il
n'y aurait pas eu leur poids je ne suis
pas sûr qu on ait pu y arriver
une démonstration de plus que c'est
vraiment le couple le moteur
franco-allemand qui est si important et
puis et puis au fur et à mesure on a
avancé un petit point que je voulais
partager avec vous parce que ça m'a
vraiment je l' ai ressenti assez
fortement au fond on a tous vécu un dans
les combats que nous menons de là où
nous sommes
le fait que l'europe doit être défendue
l'europe de tête partager leur art doit
être expliqué et moi en tout cas de là
où je suis je peux vous dire que c'est
pas de moins d'europe
dès que j'ai entendu et qu'on est venu
nous chercher nous interpeller c'est au
contraire de plus d'europe mais on veut
plus d'europe mais on veut partager
davantage mais on veut acheter des
vaccins ensemble mais on veut avoir une
politique où on puisse avoir des stocks
à partager mais on veut avoir une
capacité ensemble à s'endetter et au
fond si je retiens politiquement un des
éléments importants en tout cas disons
de la première partie de cette année et
puis ensuite évidemment de ce qui se
passe à l'automne c'est vrai que pour
nos 456 millions de citoyens européens
aujourd'hui je crois que tout le monde a
compris alors chacun évidemment se situe
là où il est évidemment sur son propre
échiquier politique
mais au fond je crois que chacun a
compris que des crises comme celle ci ne
pouvait être traitée qu'au niveau d'un
continent et qu'au fond l'évolution du
monde aujourd'hui à l'imposer d'avoir
une logique continent une europe
continent est ce effectivement les
valeurs que nous défendons les
populistes du reste sont toujours là
bien sûr il faut être attentif
enfin on les a pas beaucoup entendus
pendant cette crise partout et ce qui
était du reste aux affaires ont démontré
ce qu'ils étaient malheureusement
malheureusement pour leurs mandants
capable
de fer ou plus précisément de ne pas
faire c'est une leçon dont il faudra se
rappeler et se souvenir
mais croyez-moi nos concitoyens et nos
compatriotes non je crois bien intégré
deuxième deuxième élément donc une
europe plus efficace
c'est vrai qu'on veut plus d'efficacité
c'est vrai qu'il faut mutualiser nos
capacités d'intervention en commun c'est
vrai également que on se rend compte que
dans le les enjeux géopolitiques qui
vont décider le monde et et françois
c'est formidable qu'il soit désormais
commissaire là où il est haut
commissaire site absolument essentiel
d'avoir une capacité à avoir une
projection du temps long et dans cette
projection du temps l'ont évidemment il
va évidemment réfléchir à comment nous
positionner la france et l'europe
dans le jeu je dirais dans le nouvelle
confrontation qui sera désormais durable
entre les états unis d'un côté la chine
de l'autre côté et nous et nous l'europe
bien il faut que nous prenions de plus
en plus notre destin en main de façon
évidemment plus solidaire en s'appuyant
sur nos valeurs ce qui fonde notre socle
notre différence qui est tellement
important pour nous dire que quand on
regarde comment les choses évoluent que
ce soit du reste à l'est de notre
continent mois l'ouest je pense qu'on
peut dire que nous sommes la plus grande
la plus vieille la plus forte démocratie
du monde
en tout cas c'est clairement moins comme
ça que je vois les choses il n'en
demeure pas moins que dans
l'affrontement les confrontations qui
vont nous en doutons pas se poursuivre
notamment entre la chine et les états
unis l'europe doit de plus en plus
trouvé sa voie être autonome souverain
souveraine diront certains en tout cas
dans certains domaines
ça commence à apparaître une évidence et
c'est une bonne chose pour tout
simplement permettre permettre de
poursuivre de continuer à être ce que ce
que nous sommes
troisième enseignement dans des crises
de cette nature je dirais que les
tendances bien souvent s'accélère
évidemment je voudrais pas ne pas vous
parler ça comprendre et de tout ce que
nous sommes en train de faire sur la
réforme la régulation des grandes
plateformes de ce que j'appelle moi même
l'espace numérique l'espace
informationnel
au fond dans des grandes crises comme
celle ci bien souvent les tendances se
sont accélérées on l'avait vu lors de la
crise de 2008-2009 des subprimes avec un
impact sur les grandes banques et la
réforme du système financier qui était
devenue indispensable
certaines banques étaient du reste se
constituer tellement importante que au
fond a estimé qu'elle était plus
importante que les états et qu'elles
étaient tous big to fail trop
importantes pour pouvoir tomber que
finalement la régulation elle pourrait
l'éviter
non les états ont fait ce qu'il fallait
mais c'était bien on a augmenté les
fonds propres
on en redemande donner beaucoup plus
d'obligations notamment en matière
d'éthique de respect également de jeudi
du du droit des règles y compris ce qui
comporte ses propres comportements de
leurs propres membres de comité exécutif
ou de direction générale et c est ça a
été une bonne chose et bien dans cette
crise
dans cette crise on est bien sûr on
voyait de façon évidente notre
dépendance de plus en plus à cet espace
informationnel cet espace numérique les
grandes plateformes qui le composent
maintenant qu'ils occupent et c'est vrai
que au cours de la de la première phase
puis encore maintenant eh bien oui on a
été contraint obligé de plus en plus à
travailler dans cet espace
informationnel on y travaille on i télé
travail on
on y apprend on y apprend aussi distrait
on a des contacts sociaux pour le pour
le meilleur ou pour le pire
bien entendu on consomme de la culture
enfin on vit on vit dans cet espace
informationnelle et au fond on a tous
conscience que d'abord on a une grande
dépendance et deuxièmement que
on peut y voir et souvent ils faire un
peu tout et n'importe quoi et ça c'est
totalement intolérables et donc et donc
c'est évidemment un sentiment une
perception
une dynamique qui a été accrue par cette
crise on a donc pris le taureau par les
cornes et comme vous le savez je me suis
vraiment pencher sur cette question et
après près d'un an de travail
nous allons présenter avec ma collègue
mike jagger donc une régulation une
refonte extrêmement profonde
la première je crois depuis 2000 la
dernière c'était la directive e-commerce
ça faisait vingt ans qu'on n'avait pas
réguler ces espaces du reste le
sentiment d'impunité voir pendant cette
expression mais de far west et de zones
de non-droit et bien envers et contre
tout parce qu'évidemment les lobbys sont
puissants mais françois on n'est pas né
de la dernière pluie
je rappelle tout à l'heure donc on voit
tout ça on va donc présenter de grands
actes législatifs le 15 décembre
l'un donné des obligations désormais
extrêmement forte aux plateformes en
obligation de moyens et de résultats
notamment pour évidemment une meilleure
régulation des contenus de tous les
contenus avec un principe de base au
fond tout ce qui est autorisé dans
l'espace physique doit être ou peut
l'être dans l'espace numérique mais en
revanche tout ce qui est interdit dans
l'espace physique doit aussi l'être dans
l'espace numérique
on n'a pas le droit d'insulter son
voisin dans l'espace physique on a peur
on l'insulté non plus dans l'espace
numérique et donc on va présenter ça on
a un deuxième volet qui sera très
important et je le dis parce qu'on
aurait vraiment de votre soutien
c'est le fait qu'il faut aussi réguler
et organiser un peu mieux cet espace
numérique avec des acteurs qui sont
devenus absolument dominant je vais pas
les citer
vous avez tous en tête il faut les
réguler il faut mettre un peu maintenant
d'équité il faut limiter éliminer leurs
limites et en tout cas leurs effets de
goulots d'étranglement on dit en anglais
gate keepers ça veut bien dire ce que ça
veut dire et donc est donc tout ceci a
donné lieu à des centaines d'heures de
travail
le train les propositions sont faites le
15 décembre et et j'espère là encore une
fois que non seulement ça répondra à ce
que je sais être vos aspirations
mais que de là vous êtes vous donner un
écho favorable
on aura besoin de se battre sur ces
textes qui vont être absolument
essentiel quand on voit que le dernier
c'était il ya vingt ans on voit donc
l'importance qui est le montrent nos
mains pour sans doute les dix ou vingt
prochaines années et qu'on trouvera
l'importance du numérique y compris pour
nos valeurs y compris pour la démocratie
y compris pour tout ce qui est votre
important pour nous l'état de droit est
bien conçu voilà voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire à cette occasion pour vous
d'abord vous remercier du fond du coeur
de ce que vous faites vous passez
beaucoup de temps
chacune chacun dans vos dans vos villes
et dans vos villages dans vos
départements dans vos régions parlement
moi de mon côté évidemment la commission
je sais ce que c'est je sais ce que
c'est que cette que l'a7 cette envie de
contribuer d'apporter de participer vous
exprimer un courant de pensée qui est un
courant de pensée extrêmement important
de notre pays et dont je mesure tous les
jours killen qui sera j'en suis
absolument convaincu le courant pensée
de notre continent européen on va avoir
un rôle très important à jouer je compte
sur vous et je vous remercie